مجموعه فاجنرت تواجه جدلا واسعا نشرت هذه
المجموعه الروسيه اعلانا محليا يدعو السرب
للقتال في اوكرانيا لتقدم جماعات مناهضه
للحرب شكاوى ضد سفير الروسي
اولا بانشطه مجموعه في صربيا وثانيا
بانشطه البعثه الدبلوماسيه الروسيه في
تعبئه الصرف للتجنيد في الحرب بيوكرانيا
لم يرتكب اي خطا في تاريخ صربيا هي جريمه
يجب ان يعاقب عليها القانون
التي تاسست عام 2014 تقاتل في ثلاث قارات
اذا انها منخرطه في الحرب باوكرانيا
بغضب شديد على خطوه بتجنيد بكونها تخالف
القانون الصربي في انتقاد عالمي نادر
لروسيا
لما تفعلون ذلك لصربيا لما تطلق فاجنر
دعوه مخالفه للانظمه
يقاتل عدد ضئيل من الصلب الى جانب قوات
تدعمها موسكو في اوكرانيا منذ عام 2014
لكن السلطه السريه لم تنشر اي رقم محددا
لعدد المقاتلين الصربي هناك